the general affairs Council has thrown
its weight behind EU enlargement with
ministers saying the process remains a
key policy contributing to peace
democracy and prosperity in Europe
ministers underlined the enlargement
process must remain credible if the
momentum for reform in Nations hoping to
join the unions to be maintained
we are convinced that the text which
come came out of discussion is a is a
balanced and solid text and it emerged
clearly also that enlargement the
politics and the policy of enlargement I
would say remains remain very high on
the agenda of the European Union the EU
counts 28 member states the last to join
was Croatia in 2013. the enlargement and
the stabilization and Association
process continues with Serbia Montenegro
Macedonia Albania Bosnia and Herzegovina
and Kosovo in the western Balkans plus
turkey
ministers also supported the idea of
setting up a political Dialogue on the
rule of law within the EU to avoid any
resort to Extreme Measures in the case
of a serious breach of Union values the
temporary suspension of a state's voting
rights is the tough penalty
the council also discussed the European
commission's work program for next year
focusing on ways to improve the
functioning of the EU and the full
implementation of the Union's Lisbon
treaty ministers also cast an eye over
the draft of written conclusions
prepared for this week's Summit of EU
leaders in Brussels which will focus on
ways to improve investment in Europe and
developments in Ukraine